this is houseguest oh boy Stevens father
episode don't you just get so excited we
know the episode's gonna be about
Stephens father you know I thought that
sawing they had was touching just true
the plane the benches rides me my dear
old dad God rest his soul I do miss him
I did too we should probably call him
yeah later
his soul is actually his middle name
original name was God but he changed
yeah got a little weird
yeah well full of song yeah calling
himself bad but I think this episode's
fine it's um the the father
well continuity continuation from the
last episode which is always kind nice
they're they're fixing gets back on duty
better than doctor hooey this is his leg
appears to be heard Stephen tries to
heal it doesn't seem to work but really
it does he was a liar and he can't fix
this crack on this giant rock that if it
blows up it'll like four other bodies or
something like that it's some kids
sci-fi crap uh what does America it's
all about Stephen and him bonding they
have a nice little song together and
neither one sings it very well but
there's so much art he fakes being sick
which I hate I hate a zoo I just any
plot where that's a plot point I am it
it's like I undid sex in my my on my
list that we're gonna do biggest pet
peeves is that it's just cuz not only do
I hate the trope
I just hate people who do that that is
one of my biggest pet peeve and only do
that if you have school like that is it
or maybe like even work now has person
got a zoo residing that is a noble cause
yes um it makes sense we can almost lay
to it school started I was watching kids
ha ha ha / weird I'm just like oh God
every time I seem wait for the bus it's
like I don't
hello kids look up to us and they're
like does it get any easier Mike no but
at least I don't have to go too soon see
for me it's just taking out school
immediately makes it easier for me it's
as soon as I could leave there is like a
bad thing my god
always like our uncle calls it a
government babysitting exactly it's like
you don't learn any shit that you'll use
it we're really going off-topic but
that's only ty faking sick oh good Oh
but yeah it's I agree it's one of those
trick you know every direction it's
gonna go for the next like 10 I don't
like watching people do that cuz this is
one of my biggest pet peeves just in
life um you know people who get away
with that sort of thing so I dislike
whoever the earring boy that that we
already hated the player why freaking
faking injury and illness just yeah yeah
I feel like man we did it too with that
episode of the play water okay I will
say this Phil like and I will say this I
hated it as we kept going but when he's
like I just wanted to live with my son
again
I like total fucking sucker I'm just
like spend on me and I'm like all right
guitarists coming could you predict that
I mean it I don't know like it's it's
not to predict on this I guess that's
kind of true they're fucking imprisoning
like other gems or some shit after less
of it's like the gem zombie Bush shit's
twisted I know what's gonna happen it's
gonna be a killing spree ending bro I
know I do like how the duct tape fixes
the crack I really thought Stevens you
have to go through some sort of
emotional thing it's just like milk duct
tape it really does I did have one of
those like bad nostalgia critic lines
cuz we're watching it then he like said
like Steven like spits out his hands and
heals the gem and then the father fixes
it with duct tape oh my god duct tape
and spit reminds me of a first as no oh
you haven't fucking sit for first date
and lasting
hands me my cord appear oh my god um the
Sailor Moon appearance very very up
random ooh manga down there um why they
had to get permission for that or not um
I it's a satire I I highly doubt it I
mean you would recognize the Sailor Moon
but I doubt it
yeah I don't know I I don't know it's a
lot of stuff like somebody called Japan
and ya know it's one of those things
whenever it's like oh no lawsuit and
stuff like that it's like it's so weird
what people go after with lawsuits and
stuff some stuff it's like you know wow
you think they go after this but they're
not and then something it's like are you
fucking kidding me they're going after
this tiny stupid little thing so when we
get takedowns and like sometimes it's
the most randomest thing it's like
really that yeah that bothered you yeah
well thanks so much rain couldn't like
it could have been anything you pick
this tiny little thing like ooh you
saved yourself gods don't blow it now
everyone's gonna like at my hat Chris
refuses that up anymore um but yeah it's
why he was a Mike Myers plot I'm gonna
make a comeback I swear us about his
four-faced happening shrek 12 is on the
way I'm sure oh yeah okay I guess if I
were talking about this more the actual
episode shows is probably not a ton -
it's not bad I like a relationship with
him in this father yeah I like the
little song oh I'm still I'm still
fascinated at the whole spit heals thing
um I guess it could be worse it could be
Mysterious Girlfriend acts don't ask
just blue okay um but a lot of drool
what is leaving um but what I know but I
mean I saw I guess there's worse I I
don't know it doesn't like that so you
know why it kind of like it's random you
know you know I kind of liken it because
at first I was like really spit that's
the thing but it's kind of fun to be
like all right let's go exactly it's not
only like that's been
the hands getting raided do not screw
it's um but also I'm sure somewhere down
the line like something's got to be
healed with a kiss or something like
that like a girlfriend or somebody who
loves like cuz you know that's still the
spin everything zubik uses gonna bring
you back or say you know that's gotta be
on the horizon some perhaps perhaps um
but uh yes it's fine and even the
character I want establish the father's
not a bad character it's just what
nebulization why I'm like okay good sick
good recovery
I mean like it's one of those things
where it's not like Oh what did Stevens
mother see him this twice or whatever
it's like da no I I get it he's very
like I was loved the warp whistle I'm
like this is a freak elevator I guess so
he said was it's a warm place like
Jocelyn I was so disappointed though
when he played that yeah something for
that too maybe Natalie did beat winter
little Zelda tornado may that may for
that they did need the actual Cathy
right - um but uh yeah it's fine and you
need something a little whiter after I
think the you know the mirror episodes
the back to back so Ivy it it's totally
fine
uh yeah though this brings up another
interesting going through pulling him
away from his father
there is a darkness here to these people
I mean they say also get the way your
training your training is so so maybe it
is like just we had some strain of those
seems to consist of sitting around the
kitchen again III that just most
episodes start off like that it's like
and then you get what is essentially
fifteen minutes in some many adventures
I'm like seems like most of the day he
could probably hang out with his dad if
he wanted to yeah thank you my cousin
Hana discipline but then it's like sort
of a sick plan it's like they're
discovering stuff about to because they
don't know entirely how it works cuz
he's half human have gem but it's like
yeah you think they'd be studying even
more anti cocaine missions I gotta go
out ambitious but a lot of time they're
just hanging around the house not doing
them so it is kind of weird
Oh seems like I'm a prisoner you know
the person is Steven you can leave
whenever you want to when we tell you
you can
a person you see a prisoners held
against their will and go into oh my god
forget the name of it the you're right
the last one the chilla G after Hot Fuzz
world's at no wait
what's the World's End yeah and the
World's End that was it yeah then that
that's also easy art I was wondering
what the fuck you were talking about I
just had total brain fart which never
happens to get the world
oh but yeah well a person implies that
they can't have a lead so be it is it
maybe it's kind of like at the World's
End you know Stephen you can leave
whatever you want but we really want you
to stay under penalty of violence but uh
yeah I don't know how I'm just saying
it's getting my fishy Sisson little
weird little weird
Oh strange from my show like doesn't
seem so no I just my mind just go into
dark places watch it we'll all be
completely innocent when it's done but
I'm just like thinking ahead just like I
mean let's get twist I think they're
gonna do like a she used to watching
anime where I've seen shows start off
cute and then about the halfway point
you're like holy mock if I have a guess
it's Brian I could be too dark like
there is sort of a logic to why they're
doing certain things but it's not 100%
right that's what I'm guessing the
directions gonna go and maybe cancer
show there was a silly they've got their
own bubbly Gitmo goin then ya know I and
I think they're gonna find out that
maybe that's not the best way so that's
my guess as to what's going on at
bubbles you
and that's the thing Stephens got a
contributor yeah so yeah there is uh
what happens we will see what happens
see how many are are basically sentenced
without a fair trial
mmm good Jude military tribunal Edie boo
boo oo haha teacher no that wouldn't pay
that even way more me Stephen good news
huh he doesn't know about the three C's
you crisscrossing the references no I'm
gonna make this show better
Rob Schneider hey you know about the 3-0
fee yeah we're kind of before his name
we're Rachna a reference thank God